[Music]
yeah it's really cool you can see the
Vlogs With the women there and I'm like
oh he never coming back
let's see this
um so this is before he moved
hello I am
um
we're gonna be talking about what made
me leave to go to Brazil
in other words what made me stop dating
in the United States I've touched if
you've watched my take talk to some of
my YouTube videos you can kind of get a
perspective help but I'm gonna break it
down today so and these are in order I
believe
from severity
why I stopped dating in the United
States
the number one thing
and we're gonna say
this is uh this is actually a bunch I'm
bringing down the number one thing that
stopped me from dating the United States
was the texting games and the phone call
games the game
so we're not gonna act brand new we know
this is a thing here
you have to have some sort of game and
people get game confused with Charisma
those aren't the same thing okay
Charisma is the sweet talking in the the
emotional aspect of her getting to like
you with your words
but when I say game I'm talking about I
get your phone number now let me wait
two or three days to call you back like
if you know alpha male strategy he says
he weighs 10 days to call a woman back
why the [ __ ] would I want to do that
okay I I I get it but then that's
another thing they say oh you got to
pretend like you have options you have
to have you have to show you have
options don't blow her up all the time
text her in between five minutes uh you
know don't I've said before don't have a
routine uh all that [ __ ]
you know all this you have to have this
super strategy just to get to know
somebody or even if you just want to
smash somebody it's usually not just
it's like it's like all these tactics
that's why there's so many YouTubers and
dating coaches coming out that are just
blowing up because nobody can truly
figure this [ __ ] out right and if you're
somebody like me that's on their purpose
I'm trying to get my money right so I
can live overseas and get the hell out
of here
I don't have time for the game look baby
either you want to [ __ ] with me you
don't
and that's how my world works it's black
and white facts there is no in between
either you want to [ __ ] with me or you
don't
and that's what when you go to to Brazil
and I'm gonna compare each number to
when I went to Brazil when I went to
Brazil and I saw those Texan games
disappear
and the the you know Eve that she
wouldn't give you her number or she
would give you her number ninety percent
of the time if she gives you her number
it's going somewhere in the United
States ninety percent of the time you
give a check your number is not going
anywhere then it makes you wonder why
did you give me your number I mentioned
in a tick tock video a chick left a note
on my cartoon chicks left a note on my
car
and then I call or text
and then I can't even hook up a date
with you or hook up a time to see you um
why the [ __ ] did you leave a note on my
car um
I don't have time for that yo that's
like a bunch of
[ __ ] nobody has time for the texting
games the communication games and number
two flaking okay uh
there is a high I don't care unless if
you're some sort of super rich man or
some celebrity there is a high flake
rate in the United States so we were
teenagers we knew this right now but I
had time for that when I was a teenager
like I didn't have a job or anything I
wasn't doing [ __ ] but going to school
and going home
when I went to the mall I had to get 10
numbers or if I went to Six Flags I had
to get 10 numbers why because out of 10
numbers only three of them [ __ ]
gonna text back I don't give a [ __ ] what
nobody says only three of those are
gonna text you back and I out of those
three two or maybe one or maybe two
you're gonna see again
it's it's just that
it's I don't care anybody tells you
otherwise it's full of [ __ ] unless
there's some sort of celebrity but
they're not living the regular lifestyle
like this so as an adult
I knew that going to okay probably still
the same thing I still gotta uh approach
a lot of women but then it was just
coming back like damn the flake rate it
seemed like the flake rate has gotten
worse and I know some dumbass watching
this video right now is gonna be like
look in the mirror look in the mirror
that's not the [ __ ] problem because
this there's a abundance of men saying
the same thing and then you hear about
these women wanting to uh just have
validation and social media and cell
phones have created this where they have
access to so many men they'll flake on
you in a minute
yeah
he's really funny though he always is
like modern women they're that bad
I I
um
I hear him with the games yeah yeah
those games like they're tedious oh bro
like
the thing is um with the flake rates
actually I would love the Pearl your
your uh opinion on this when it comes to
the Sexes men or women which one of them
flake on you more when it comes to
guests coming onto the show oh God I oh
I have strong hands
I have strong feelings I feel like a
dude I don't do the recruiting anymore
thank you Jesus oh my God I'm Catholic
but oh my god when I did the recruiting
it was like you get it the flag rate for
women if they said yes I will be at the
show 50 and half of them won't even tell
you they're not coming they just don't
show up the men
um I would say like 20 will flake on you
20. unless they're athletes the flake
rate goes up I don't know what it is
about that I'll be honest I had a woman
who said that she was gonna come today
the issue flake they always do yeah yeah
yeah except you guys good job
you know I was tempted
but yeah but those those texting that
those texting games are real like when
he said you even [ __ ] me you don't I
felt that yeah
no but the thing is as women you're
already know that I ain't got time to
hear that because you as women you
already know that there are guys that
have got your number and you ain't gonna
text them back 100 I was having a
conversation with one of my female
friends and she was um it was it was an
Intrigue for me because I'm like why do
women give out their numbers the guys
are not interested in yeah and he made a
good point when it comes to validation
and she was like sometimes I can't be
bored we might not be interested in but
we might want to see where it's going
and I'm like you would never catch a guy
giving a number to a woman he is not
interested in it for one because any
holes a goal that's why they just want
to smash
well then if you don't want to smash
donkeys
I don't give the number don't get a
number like there's been times where
I've been on the phone I'm hearing it
happening and she's saying like I've got
to give my number but some guys don't
take Nova either which is a fair point
yeah they're like
yeah
sometimes it's actually easier to give
your number I'd give the wrong number
yeah yeah the wrong number but a lot of
them are texting back still a lot of
them are still communicating and a lot
of them are saying well I'm being boring
with my reply so he should take the hint
but I'm like if a guy knows you're going
to reply whether it's a boring reply or
not you're still replying and to him
he's going to keep texting yeah the
thing is this whole no women don't do
honesty very well that's what the thing
it's not I mean I've seen it there's an
entire strategy behind the the online
game or texting game
um I've got this entire thing mapped out
but as far as
it's a whole thing about Plenty of Fish
but as far as women uh flaking on you
first of all I think some of that is to
do with like a woman gives you her
number but she wants to still be chased
so chase me Chase me so I feel some of
that is probably in that scenario where
women want to be chased I think still
women want to to get a man I think
they're running away from me I feel like
okay I feel like for me and you guys can
tell me if this is true I feel like
um if guys there's three boxes immediate
yes immediate no
um on the no there's no coming out of
that you like never and then there's
like maybes yeah yeah and then so it's
like like maybe
um like I like something about them or I
don't maybe yeah and so if a guy's like
a maybe I feel like
like I forget if I'm not responding like
I feel like I'm just not that into him I
would hate to be a maybe I prefer to be
a no than a baby that's how you guys hit
that yeah yeah I'd hate I prefer to be a
no dinner I think sometimes it's like
you know I've met something that you
meet somebody and you're like you know
what they're like you said there's so
many attributes about them you're like
why don't like what what is that missing
so you think because some relationships
can grow over time so it's like maybe
you see and it's that mentality that no
I'm just saying that that puts girls in
positions where they're giving out their
numbers because it's based on the
presumption of hope that it can grow
into something even though you're not
interested at the time and to piggyback
off that the hope is that he does
something awesome that makes you change
your mind not you when you walk into a
relationship situation where you're
waiting for someone else to make it good
then you're not going to put your best
foot forward and it's probably not gonna
work yeah let me ask a woman a question
actually do you it's random do you think
that you have to work for the guy or the
guy who has to work for you I think it's
both I think yeah yeah I think yeah the
Ty thing definitely what do you think
most women think yeah
um
do you think most women have some guys
where they're gonna go that extra mile
for and then there's like everyone else
yeah if I see potential in somebody I
100 go there the flakiness I haven't
really noticed much flakiness in women
but he's acting like you know it happens
all the time
it's bound to happen if you're taking 10
to 20 numbers yeah
so if you're putting yourself out there
you're you're bound to come across
remember flaky I mean the thing is I
think a guy who looks like you probably
doesn't get as much flakes as a guy that
looks like me we come from different
words
we always go out and one of my friends
on regular basis like continues to get
five to ten numbers a night so if he's
getting five to ten ten numbers a night
he knows that out of that 10 he's
looking at possibly meeting two of them
by the end of the chains and and because
he knows how many at least out of ten
numbers he'll get two of them that he'll
eventually get to the point of actually
going on a date okay and out of those
two uh potentially one of them is
probably a sexual partner and the other
one might flake on that so really we're
winding down to that I mean that's the
strategy that as I said with POF is I
start on a Sunday and by Wednesday I am
on a telephone call by Thursday Friday
I'm arranging a date for either a Friday
or the Saturday and then out of those
Friday or Saturday dates potentially one
of them will
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible